hello and welcome to this video playing
tacticals here with black long time made
veggie sir that's the guy okay I'm
playing the Queen's indian i recently
got a book about this opening and maybe
i'm studying it a little bit in behalf I
place that line and this is very
critical and check I don't really feel
qualified to play the sharpest reply
with them yeah with c5 but the thought
this is also decent how does that work
actually hmm we should bag he's good
efore though and it looks a little bit
threatening ABT five I'm really making
up things here as I as I go along now
why does a little bit better him but
okay that can happen if you play an
opening you experiment with and don't
know the critical line the critical main
line then stuff like that can happen
okay anyway let's see how to play him
knight c6 Queen D son
hmm yeah he wants me to Castle short
that's for sure and in general i'd like
to cancel short but yeah at the moment
this looks rather threatening 95 and
yeah getting the night over to e6 he I'm
also covering the c7 square yeah okay
maybe this one night only six is my
absolute key p.m.
yeah this is fields okay now I don't
think I'm I'm Lucia um ok so what to do
maybe I still should prevent any thing
to come to g5 I want the rukon d aid
maybe this rookie aid I can also play
for c5 red rook c8 and c5 also not bad
at all yeah so c5 and rook a4 maybe I
think you also wants to maybe maybe get
the F porn rolling let's do this on
therefore i have f 594 maybe first
and now h5 looks right for him okay no
I'm happy to do that okay let's see okay
I cannot unite the eight quite clearly
but is also it is not threatening much
yeah I think
I wonder if 95's move but probably not i
can take with the pawn I guess okay yeah
I cannot play 98 head slightly it's
unpleasant but other than that he cannot
do very much can try to bring the Knight
to c3 but this takes quite a while
a b5 he's got 85 that's not a good idea
to be honest okay
yeah of course that's interesting it
tries to play for win with that exchange
sacrifice it's probably enough for white
and I be high if it's the thing is I've
got rougarou guys 6b five is not not
good probably or not probably very
likely it's not good ok try whoopsie ate
here check yeah now I mean I can go I
can advance him and enter once you form
come on let's do that it's it's playing
passively it's probably not great it
rarely is anyway but ok this move
like to trade a rook betrayed his rook
I'm okay at least I think I'm okay
getting objectively has to make a draw
now with repeating playing for when I
don't think it's justified for what but
we will see what happens I can continue
to pursue as Rukia
no I think he must make it wrong like
rugby sevens rugby aid and so on I can
maybe play for a window okay Luke see a
drupe a six Bishop before okay come on I
scott d 50 come on this is this is crazy
I just have a draw then i blundered this
nonsense come on thats its you good
morning I'm so stupid yeah of course I
see it immediately after i play move him
it's it's not grand not difficult ah
very very stupid stuff check check
yeah it's still I mean it's probably
losing but it's so interesting a corn is
dangerous all of the Sun this pause
point is also dangerous 9292 I've got
this okay check that's a lightly the
scales I that's very lucky after i
blundered d5 yeah the correct result is
a draw I think with white is this kind
of this kind of repetition is logical
here i guess um got a computer things
are ten loops I can play for a win here
but this how does this you want to play
for win with this okay yeah of course I
mean this is not possible and a five
check check check this is the line that
the engine is cheating but I don't quite
get adjusted R alright so perpetual more
or less here the Sisson it's the very
dangerous with the pawns ok let's let's
have a look at this game the the thing
is that this line Queens the tool leads
to very crazy complications after c5 d5
Bishop here I think Bishop here so
something like that but this is all I
know and it's very dangerous for black
and yet I don't know that so I played
some some some some secondary line that
felled like playable and not yeah not
critical but playable yeah and he I
think I should be all right I can go see
five here already which looks like an
equalizer but okay I don't think this is
bad I was very surprised that you didn't
play h5 that's totally normal here to
prevent h5 so that this and this kinga 3
and g4 becomes possible um no he played
this surprisingly no I can close that
down yeah i mean in this position um
it's kind of clear that um black can't
stay eric and i can just do nothing at
all and the same applies for wide I
guess yeah yeah this is interesting this
rook see 60 HZ 66 I wanted to do
something here but I don't really see
how I mean I was thinking about I'm
sorry 95 but he can take with this and
this is felt felt dangerous I maybe c5
is on okay so this is what I could have
played I could have played that night so
far yeah here why it definitely has
enough compensation this is clear here
already t5 was possible yeah we just
didn't see that as the nit for is good
here while there's a lot better so rube
d8 is bad I have to go king of seven and
step then rook a7 and me five yeah the
engine claims this is equal that might
be true but it is awkward to play why
this calling the shots him check it the
way it went
we I should have played be sure before
probably yeah as I said the draw is kind
of the most likely result and then then
I have figured that we should be four
oaks CA this could be interesting and I
just blundered chef I've yeah here I'm
losing check him out of multiple ways
check yeah I here rookie five wins
rookie camp check check check something
like that is winning according to the
engine after that it's surprisingly
already okay for me right yeah I'm
better yeah it's a crazy game sometimes
okay thanks for watching